the game would will you then start
looking at the next pawn
to make it or will the queens be able to
take those off
you also look at the situation when the
queens are on the board you will be
looking at the
like the next pawns i mean do you have a
safe haven for the king
now it's very it's been very very
critical where to put the king you
do not necessarily want to put the king
in a place where it could be
checked and uh that a black would have
managed to trade of queens okay and we
do have the queens on the board we do
and
we did see that race uh kind of finish
itself
very quickly there both players had seen
that in advance now lots and lots of
checks
and white queen giving check attacking
the black king but also attacking
black's pawn
now we'll see black eliminate the final
white pawn and the queens
get traded off both sides so unhappy
both players
know they had missed chances and a draw
i kind of feel that it's a sigh of
relief as well though for
magnus carlsen still sitting there he is
still in contention definitely but
it was dangerous for the world champion